[suspenseful music]
♪ ♪
This is 288, I'm investigating
the report of a disturbance.
(over radio)
Roger that, 288.
♪ ♪
Freeze!
Because I got a popsicle,
you think--
Gun!
[heroic music]
♪ ♪
[suspenseful music]
Oh, rats.
(both)
Whoa.
Watch out!
That black guy's got a gun
and he's gonna steal
your banana!
(both)
What?
[shouting]
[heroic music]
Go. Go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go go, go, go, go.
Come on.
Sir!
You're gonna have
to leave the area.
There's been a disturbance.
Go.
For your safety, sir.
Go now.
Please.
Okay. Go, go, go.
Get going.
[shouts]
Big fuzzy gun!
[shouting]
[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
I mean, it was like,
it was like, you know, a holiday
for people having guns.
God damn it!
Mayor's on a warpath.
Who's responsible for this mess?
I'm sorry, Chief.
It was me.
Gun!
[shouting]
God damn it!
Coffee cup.
My bad.
00:02:10.697,00:00:00.000
Anyway, the last seven
came out of nowhere.